the real life football star of The Blind
Side is claiming that his adoption was
all a lie and he's claiming that the
family that took him into their home as
a high school student actually made
Millions off of his name retired NFL
star Michael Orr claimed in court that
the tuis tricked him into signing a
document that gave the family authority
to make business decisions decisions and
that was only at the beginning they
ended up striking a movie deal that
talked about their relationship with ore
which paid them millions of dollars in
royalties all this while ore didn't
receive a dime The Blind Side earned
almost 300 million dollars and the tuis
continued to use his name to help
promote their foundations and once Orr
hired a lawyer to dig into the details
of the movie deal he found out that the
two he's never even actually adopted him
he's now petitioning to end their
relationship and to have the couple pay
him to share